Jimmy Butler is a bully oh here we go
you don't know me you only know what I
allow you to see but you would click to
try to call me out of a train to Penn
Station to get on another train we are
on the train going in an hour south to
someone else we went to interview the
Enigma that is Jimmy Butler and we are
going to get to the core I'm Jimmy
butters lots of stuff in here Jimmy you
got a billion things going on how are
you I'm fantastic how you doing great so
um we've completely taken over your home
for sure we're all here just to figure
out who is Jimmy Butler it's what I tell
a lot of people you don't know to me you
only know what I allow you to see when
it comes to what you read in the media I
nobody knows what I really do on a daily
basis I'm sure you'll find out here
pretty soon to say the least I am myself
okay so for every guest we do a take it
there segment so I'm gonna ask you a
series of questions and you're gonna
take me to that moment or that
okay take me to your potential free
agency decision this summer I can't take
it when that moment gets here I'm gonna
be fun but it'll be a moment that's too
far away to worry about right now
take me to a day and Tomball Texas when
I was there it was kind of like if you
got bored
take your ass outside and do something
country type stuff now like we got like
two Walmart
we got a chick-fil-a crazy I don't even
recognize I think I'm in downtown
Houston when I go through samba take me
to your first game of spades spades of
clay for a while but memorable game
whenever I was in college a lot of
cheating was going on back in the day
dough he doesn't think anyone's gonna be
my partner in space little bit you know
I'm probably better than everyone in
this house like la basura you know what
that means yeah trash trash all right
time for Spades you have it in the
winners and the suttas where the winner
is you listen that's what you want to
believe were you a good kitchen or a car
or did you get in trouble don't get a
job did you does not get caught when you
got in come on I'll get in trouble
tries to beat him to the spot right
shoulder in that's close so we can agree
you're confrontational you've described
your hair okay I like you and you say
that you feed off of confrontation in
what ways has that helped your career I
think it's gotten me to the point that I
am at in my career
if I was in the NBA and I played in
Philadelphia I want to live in the city
but Jimmy living so far out is so
indicative of who Jimmy is I don't
bother nobody
yeah I did it myself me and my guys
every single day we do the same stuff
we wake up early we'll go train or do
some Pilates get my core right
we'll shoot crack jokes on each other
all day when I'm in my home
I'm carefree like I don't worry about
nothing I don't worry about what people
say I think I read an article where oh
oh oh here we go
article what article did you read what
do you think that's what people do I
don't even know what you're gonna say
but just think about this the article
that you read they only let you know
what they want you to know well I think
that you're gonna be very surprised over
the answer but you were quick to try to
call me I'm just saying just throwing it
I did I read an article once that said
that you like to journal mm-hmm is that
true is that accurate that is that's
very accurate okay how often do you
journal I don't know a lot at least once
a day just because as much as going on
in my life at any certain time I need to
write it down because I may need a vent
I'm human like everybody else so what
are some of the things that you find
yourself journaling about more than
others I mean obviously basketball cause
that's a big part of my life how am I
gonna make sure that everybody in my
group of people and my crew can put food
on the table for them in their family
that's the main thing that's on my mind
because if my guys are okay I know I'm
gonna be okay they're happy I'm happy
okay so we know what happiness looks
like for you what does sadness look like
to you I'm sitting in my room don't
knock on my damn door don't talk to me
that's that's the gist of it by myself
tell me the time that sticks out that
you were the most sad I will probably
say when I wanted to quit basketball
forever and Marchetti
and I was like you know what goodbye
some other thing for me I wish I would
have had a drum there to get it all out
instead of just talking myself in the
dark and I was like man I don't know
what to do who to talk to who can relate
well talk to me about that moment why
did you want to quit basketball why was
it I mean you're so far away from home
and tattoos I didn't do no research I
didn't know that it snowed I know that
it got cold
I didn't know anything so I went up
there like I was still in Texas
basketball shorts t-shirts flip-flops
the one person that did help me though I
will tell you this joke folks we went to
Marquette together so I was like
whenever we had a problem we're each
other's kind of coping mechanism the
fact that you just had somebody to
listen to definitely helped yeah and I
go to therapy every week I think that
it's the most amazing thing just what
you go through like retail therapy like
you're going shopping
no like I go I mean usage of wine um but
you're right therapy comes in many
different forms and it almost seems like
that journals a therapy thing able to
talk to someone even if they aren't
listening tea was a therapy but I'm
curious if you've ever thought about
doing actual therapy done it before
tell me about it I mean I think there's
a better way for me to talk to people
and handle things I like when people
tell me to like just stop being a [ __ ]
right yeah suck it up how well do you
guys know each other as partners you
know what he's gonna do and that just
comes the time just like shoot a free
throw
I got nervous we had so I have a very
serious hard-hitting question what is up
with the Ninja Turtle headband it's not
a ninja turtle head it is a ninja turtle
headband it's like the donnatal because
it is in the back and it flows for one
you couldn't you could say I feel okay
but that's not what it is okay then tell
me what why are you doing that I reward
drew so you know what let me get you
know Tata
they have they around my neck if we want
somewhere there's a boat what's it like
being on a basketball team with a
personality like Joelle indeed different
let me tell you that I like it cuz he
got some of I don't give a [ __ ] buy
yo I'm going at you but here tell you
like that's what I like about it like
yeah hi we cool but I'm Finnell finna
bust your ass tonight like I like that I
like being on a team of four it
competitive who controls the music I'm a
locker room not Amir Johnson uh I heard
his playlist before the game one of
these home games trashed terrible what's
the mood of your playlist right now
probably some Scotty McCreery mr. Tim
penny drunk me is a great song but I
think the song on the album and uh walk
like him
phenomenal phenomenal these are all
country artists yeah yeah we country
here what made you start listening to
country music because that seems
different than what people would expect
it all started just like getting on
peoples nerves and college everybody's
wearing
the Beats headphones around their neck
instead of on their ears like normal
people do and you can hear the music
solo and from this corner Wiz Khalifa
Jeezy Drake name it it was all in there
and I was if I yo turn your music now
now as I know my own business pay
attention and listen what's in your
headphone that's right say no more
got you so next game rolls around and I
walk in the same way that they were with
the headphones right here blaring Tim
McGraw don't take the girl ever I was
like turn that [ __ ] off and other no
hell no remember what y'all just told me
my your business and listen to us and
your headphones so I actually started
listening to the lyrics and I'll
actually like the music so I stuck with
it you claim to be a better football
player than Antonio Brown yes with that
being said I could be in debt thirty
thousand to him right now because I
tried to guard him in a red zone
and failed one of the best wide
receivers in the league you bet him
$30,000 hypothetically speaking I
started at 10 he could or could not have
went 3 for 3 3 times 10 is 30 I'm just
saying it couldn't happen you thought
you would best a B once half a day we're
speaking yes was it a reach
hypothetically hypothetically could have
hypothetically been a bad way to lose
hypothetically 30,000 oh yeah yeah hey
Taylor the bet was he could stop me for
three fate routes from Russell Wilson
hey Jim you know you one of my close
friends and y'all credit always go with
me but I think today you need to pay pay
up buddy has been three years
I just don't answer my charity what's
that do you shine a bucket
Jimmy buckets yeah you do not care what
people think of you yeah I hear that I
think that most people do care but there
are certain things that they believe
that they do know about you I wanted to
say some of those things and I want your
take
their beliefs okay okay Jimmy Butler is
a diva honey like being in spotlight I
don't even like being on TV
I'm like no media he's got to do it no
but I think the way that people write a
story or narrate something I see where
you could get that from not mad at it
Jimmy Butler is a bully stop it that's
him
really you want to use that word with
everything that's going on in the world
right now to try to say that I'm a bully
Who am I bullying in Jimmy Butler is
toxic once again don't think so I got
way too much of my life going on to be
worried about if somebody things that
I'm talk to you
I'll actually think that majority of my
teammates that I play with we was cool
Jimmy Butler is not a max player that is
to be determined I don't play this game
for the bread anyway you say you know
you let them think what they want to
think I like it though yeah I want
everybody know I mean what fun is that
I'd actually like more people to dislike
me cuz then you really pay attention you
know you take whatever I say and choose
to accept it believe it not like me even
more just be you like imma be me whether
you like it or not I don't give in the
way that I like to say it I don't give a
[ __ ] I think [ __ ] is your favorite cuss
word yeah you're a [ __ ] guys yeah yeah
yeah what's your second favorite custard
i [ __ ]
oh so just a variation of [ __ ] yeah okay
you know you got put that one in there
did we win yes that's even a garbage can
gets its takeaways you out it wise words
you Robert hey allegedly the greatest
yeah I don't say he's up the basketball
games I'm gonna shake hands
you better move damn refrigerator this
is why I like me on this side you take
it tell you what I'm not holding phones
if I drop it I'm not paying for what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content